[Music]  it's time for et social study what the  stars are posting online dance off bro  me and you Chris Pratt chairs production  stills after spending the day on set of  guardians of the galaxy volume 2 but  we're loving his captions after he  admits he's four shots of vodka deep do  I miss my wife and son right now yes is  my elbow hurt from over doing some stunt  stuff yes in my fruit down a little by  the pressure probably but here's what's  also true we're killing it killing it  rumer willis models in a 90s inspired  gap campaign paying homage to her mom  Demi Moore's 1990s Hilary Duff sharing  this leggy photo with an empowering  message I didn't always love my legs but  as I've grown I've learned to love and  celebrate myself just as I am did he  snaps from his hospital bed after his  third knee surgery in a year sharing  flowers he got from French Montana and  Sofia Vergara shares an incredible  throwback photo feeding her now 24 year  old son manolo when he was an infant